[Music]
you know our our society has become so
clickbait tea and superficial it's very
seldom in interview situations that
you're asked anything of substance the
thing I get asked the most often is so
tell us about this movie why should we
go see it to which I always want to
answer don't go see it go yourself
I think yeah I'm not like that's not my
job to tell you why you should go see
this movie because you want to but it it
just goes to show how lazy most media
outlets are you know and so ignore all
of the channels ignore all channels of
popular culture and focus on what you
like and what you and your friends
and/or family like because the stuff
that I grew up that was like my weird
bits that I did with my cousin and my
sisters and brother the stuff that I
thought was weird or that stood out to
me I focused on that and through my
theater training and then through my
career it was always the counterculture
weirdness that spoke to me there's a
very specific group of us and we find
each other and say oh now we're 47 let's
make a TV show and so by focusing and if
you if you just you know if you if you
just consume what's being fed to you
then you never find out if there's a
really stinky cheese that might be your
favorite thing to eat one thing that
really attracted me to this script I had
worked on the previous film the hero
with Brett and his co-writer Mark Bosch
and there there's I find them to be such
wonderfully mature writers which is
annoying and Brett because he's like 33
but he makes these really thoughtful
movies about humanity and I loved when I
read the script and
there's this there's this element of the
father-daughter relationship where they
kind of take turns at who's being the
parent and who's being the kid and I
thought that was really attractive and
fun to play and and realistic you know
it's it's a strange thing to see a kid
want to go away and become a doctor and
and not only that but like we see her
studying hard she's a an erudite student
she's very serious about where she's
going and yet she has this musical
talent that she doesn't take as
seriously and to see the dad sort of
saying come on I really want you to
think about throwing away all here
responsible dreams and run away and join
the circus with me your dad I grew up in
a very conservative small town in
Illinois in a very conservative family
every it's an amazing family of heroes
there's about 30 of us now in this
extended family and I'm the only one
that doesn't live within an eight-mile
radius and every single family member is
either farmer school teacher librarian
paramedic nurse and we have one craft
brewer my brother he's the king of the
family but I'm the only one and I always
had this idea that I wanted to entertain
people but I'd I didn't have the the
culture coming in to I never learned of
the channels by which I might achieve
that and so when I was a junior in high
school and you had to begin to declare
what do you want to do where do you want
to go to college if so and and it was
pretty wild that I said I think I want
to become an actor and the whole county
was like no no I don't don't believe you
can do that from here and I said well I
but those other people must have come
from somewhere and really like all the
channels like the guidance counselor
school had a list of the 36 things you
could study and and not only was actor
not on there there were no arts on there
the only one was musician one guy from
my town had become had gone to music
school and he became a band director at
a college and and so that was their
their precedent and they said what are
you gonna do what do you want to do go
be a band director at a college it was
like no I want to like you know make
people laugh or I want to be in it be in
movies and stuff and so it was pretty
crazy but here's where some serendipity
happened I I was with my girlfriend who
was auditioning for a dance department
at the University of Illinois I met some
theater students and I said what the
hell are you talking about your theater
students and they said we study theater
and I said well then what they said you
go to Chicago and you get paid to be in
plays and I said you got to be kidding
me this is what I'm talking about it was
like went went home was like mom dad I'm
gonna go do plays and then I go to
Chicago and they pay me to do plays
that's the thing people do it and so
that's what I did and it my mom and dad
were very supportive I was somebody who
had crazy ideas but I worked really hard
they gave me a wonderful work ethic and
they said you have some real cockamamie
schemes but you always do your best and
so well we'll get behind you and you
know support you in this and it took
several years and in your--in from age
18 to 26
those are formative years that's a tough
scary time for your parents to say okay
we're gonna trust you but eventually you
know when they first came to see me in a
Shakespeare play in a very small part at
a big theater in Chicago there was a big
moment for me where I was like wow see
this is this is something three lines
you know there are people in this show
with no lines
just watch me and you know it's
something that it's it's a very personal
thing and you have to trust your gut the
world is always gonna want you to do
other things that make them feel safe
you know parents especially often have
their own desires and so to parents and
children alike I would say trust your
gut again if you've lived one of these
lives where you are in a household where
there's not people aren't using tools or
people aren't that practical you know
there's a lot of urban and suburban
households where people say yeah God you
know when when I get a flat tire I have
to buy a new car because I don't know
what to do or if a light bulb goes out I
have to throw the lamp away because I
couldn't tell you how that thing works I
don't think I have the right tools to
those households of which there are many
I would say find a place to try making
stuff and it there's so many things you
can do and another great thing about the
Information Age or the the proliferation
of Technology is that you can literally
learn to do anything now on YouTube you
can become a blacksmith just from
YouTube you're you're gonna learn a lot
faster if you find a blacksmith to show
you that's that's true of anything if
you have a teacher there but uh but just
try stuff you know I love influencing
the kids in my life and I just do my
best to let him try stuff and you know
some of them like to paint some of them
like - some of them like to help in the
kitchen some of them this one kid likes
to just punch trees he's he's troubled
and we're gonna try him out in sports
but we'll see he might he might make a
great lumberjack
[Music]
you